so when to use the law of cosines use
the law of cosines when you have a non
right triangle so you don't have a
90-degree angle and the other time that
used law of cosines in addition to not
having a right angle is if you are only
given three sides side side side or side
angle side for example the angle okay in
between two sides and that's all you
know so here are the formulas and you
can see there's three of them that you
can use depending on what angles and
what sides they give you but I want you
to kind of see the pattern see notice
that in this generic triangle here that
angle a and siding are across from each
other angle B and side B R across from
each other angle C and side C the
lowercase letters are the sides and the
capital letters are the angles so here
you can see here side C here is angle C
here's side B here's angle B here's side
a here's angle a and you can see they're
across from each other just like they're
across from each other in the diagram
the other two letters B and C a and C a
and B a and B so you can see there's you
know definitely a pattern here that
helps you to remember these formulas if
you just remember one of them you'll be
able to figure out the other two so let
me show you an example okay the first
example I'm going to show you we're
going to do the side angle side scenario
so say for example they give you a
triangle like this say this is 60
degrees say this is 4 say this is 8 and
you want to solve for this side over
here let's just call this side C okay so
we're going to be working with this top
formula here okay so that means that
this is uh we'll call this B we'll call
this a we'll call this angle C okay so
you've got a and B and you're looking
for side C it's across from angle C so
what we have here is we have C squared
equals 4 squared plus 8 squared so the
two sides squared that make up that
angle minus 2 times 4 times
e times the cosine of the included angle
here 60 degrees so you can see there's
your side angle side and we're solving
for the side across from angle see here
here's side see here's angle C and B are
the two other sides that make up that
angle okay so all we have to do is solve
this and then take the square root to
solve for C so what we have here let's
simplify 16 plus 64 is 80 okay and this
is 2 times 4 is 8 times 8 is 64 times
the cosine of 60 cosine of 60 is 1/2 so
we have 80 minus 32 which is 48 okay and
if we take the square root of both sides
we get the square root of 48 and that's
going to be the length of this side and
you can simplify this a little bit more
this is 16 times 3 which is 4 square
root of 3 okay so that's an example
where you have side-angle-side
let's do an example where they give you
3 sides ok side side side so an example
in this case would be something like
this say you're given five six and seven
okay they're giving you just three sides
and you want to solve for let's say this
angle right here we'll call it angle C
again so this would be side C side a and
B okay so what we have here is we have
seven squared okay equals five squared
plus six squared minus two times five
times six times the cosine of angle C
okay now what you want to do is you want
to get this cosine C by itself on one
side of the equation and then take the
cosine inverse of both sides to solve
for angle C so what we're going to do is
we're going to do this in steps we have
49 equals 25 plus 36 which is 61 minus
60 cosine C now here's where some
students make a mistake they'll combine
these and they'll say oh that's one but
you see this is a group these are all
multiplying to get
okay what you want to do is you want to
work from the outside in towards this
cosine to get it by itself so I would
subtract 61 from both sides so that
would give you negative 12 equals
negative cosine see negative sorry
negative 60 cosine see and then you
divide both sides by negative 60 which
equals cosine C and that comes out to
1/5 which is 0.2 and you take the cosine
inverse of both sides you're going to
get C equals the cosine inverse of 0.2
so let's just see what that comes out to
real quick here on our calculator we
have let's see you'll do it in degrees
okay degrees cosine inverse 0.2 78 point
five degrees so that's this angle right
here seventy eight point five now if you
want to solve for these other two angles
now you can use the law of sines you
only have to use law of cosines at most
once you can use law of sines to find
this angle then you have two angles you
can add those up and subtract from 180
and then you've solved the triangle you
found all the sides all the angles so
this has been the law of cosines go
ahead and review the video if you need
to I'll see you in the next video